les chiffres demandés par monsieur
collombat sur le nombre d'agents ont
contaminé les premiers éléments que nous
avons et pardonnez ma prudence mais les
premiers éléments que nous avons
montrent que dans la fonction publique
d'état y dans la fonction publique
territoriale
je ne dispose pas d'éléments pour la
fonction publique hospitalière il n'y a
pas de prévalence particulière de du
virus chez les agents publics
par contre nous ne disposons pas de
chiffres consolidés
nous les avons demandé aux différents
ministères pour avoir un premier regard
sur le nombre de personnes concernées
dans la fonction publique d'état
c'est une demande qui sera faite aux
collectivités territoriales avec cette
particularité vous connaissez très bien
qui est que les employeurs territoriaux
sont au nombre de plus 48 milles lorsque
l'on tient compte de toutes les
structures et que le délai de
consolidation et est important sur la
question des équipements c'est un point
qui est important l'état pour ce qui
concerne la fonction publique d'état
travaillent à obtenir et a commandé des
masques et des équipements de protection
en nombre
nous avons été destinataires de
plusieurs livraisons souvent partagés
entre plusieurs ministères
ce qui nous laisse penser que l'on 11
mai nous aurons suffisamment
d'équipements de protection pour
accompagner les agents qui ont besoin
d'agents de protection
et je précise que l'ordre de priorité
tant la distribution dans la délivrance
des équipements de protection ne sera
paré départ nous mais bien par les
instants ce type dgs secrétariat général
de la défense et cellule
interministérielle que j'ai évoqués
précédemment
le secrétariat général à la défense et
la sécurité nationales ayant déjà établi
une liste de corps ou de cadres
d'emplois pourraient être considérés
comme prioritaires